♪ ♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING, AND
WELCOME TO A SPECIAL EDITION OF
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
ACCORDING TO YOUR NUMBERS, THE
DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY RACE IS
CONSTRUCTING TO BECOME REALLY A
TWO MAN CONTEST.
A LOT OF PEOPLE IN THE RACE BUT
THE OUTLINE IS CLEAR.
ON ONE SIDE, YOU HAVE THE
CANDIDATE BERNIE SANDERS WHO
WANTS TO TURN THIS COUNTRY INTO
A CONFERENCE OF WELFARE STATE.
LOOKED UP AND EVERY ASPECT OF
AMERICAN LIFE TO IMPOSE A NEW
ECONOMIC ORDER.
SANDERS IS NOT HIDING WHAT HE
WANTS TO DO.
HE’S RUNNING ON WHAT HE WANTS TO
DO.
HIS MAIN RIVAL IS MICHAEL
BLOOMBERG, THE FORMER MAYOR OF
NEW YORK.
BLOOMBERG HAS SHOT TO ABOUT 15%
NATIONALLY IN THE POLLS FROM
NOWHERE, ESSENTIALLY.
HE’S SUDDENLY LEADING THE RACE
IN THE CRITICAL SUPER TUESDAY
STATE OF FLORIDA.
WHAT IS MIKE BLOOMBERG RUNNING
ON?
THAT’S A TRICK QUESTION,
ACTUALLY.
BLOOMBERG ISN’T RUNNING ON
ANYTHING.
NOT BECAUSE HE HAS IDEAS, HE HAS
PLENTY OF IDEAS AND SOME OF THEM
ARE FAR OUTSIDE THE AMERICAN
MAINSTREAM.
BUT BLOOMBERG DOES NOT THINK
ANYTHING MATTERS BUT HE’S NOT
RUNNING ON IDEAS.
NOT TRYING TO CONVINCE VOTERS OF
ANYTHING.
HE’S NOT MAKING ARGUMENTS OR
WORKING TO CHANGE THEIR MINDS ON
POLICIES THAT THEY CARE ABOUT.
HE’S TRYING TO BUY THEM AND THE
PRESIDENCY.
IT’S THE SINGLE MOST CYNICAL
POLITICAL CAMPAIGN RUN IN THIS
COUNTRY AND BLOOMBERG IS TRYING
TO SUBVERT OUR DEMOCRACY WITH
CASH AND IS GOING ALL IN THE DO
IT.
ACCORDING TO LATEST NUMBERS,
BLOOMBERG AND SPENT MORE THAN
FOUR TO $17 MILLION IN
ADVERTISING SO FAR IN THIS RACE.
HIS NEAREST RIVAL HAS BEEN
$40 MILLION, THAT’S LESS THAN A
TENTH.
JOE BIDEN, THE MAN WHO THEY TOLD
US IT IS A FRONT RUNNER SPENT
3.3 MILLION.
SAY THAT AGAIN TO THE AT LEAST
THE 417 MILLION LUBRICANTS
PUMPED INTO THE RACE JUST ON
ADVERTISING.
THAT’S JUST THE BEGINNING.
THE NUMBER COULD GO HIGHER.
NOTHING LIKE THIS HAS EVER
HAPPENED IN AMERICA.
BLOOMBERG’S SPENDING IS, AND
PICK YOUR METAPHOR HERE, US AND
I’LL BE BREAKING OVER OUR
POLITICAL SYSTEM.
WHEN THE WATERS RECEDED, THERE’S
NOTHING LEFT.
IT’S BEEN FLATTENED AND WIPED
CLEAN BY THE WAKE OF MIKE
BLOOMBERG’S WEALTH.
THE TALLEST FIGURE IN THE
LANDSCAPE, ONLY ONE LEFT
UPRIGHT.
THAT’S HIS PLAN FOR ALL BUT
ADMITTED THAT HIS PLAN.
WATCHING YOUR DISAVOWAL STOP AND
FRISK, THE SINGLE MOST
SUCCESSFUL POLICY HE HAD AS
MAYOR OF NEW YORK.
>> I DEFENDED IT LOOKING AT IT
TOO LONG BECAUSE I DIDN’T
UNDERSTAND THE UNINTENDED PAIN
IT WAS CAUSING TWO YOUNG BLACK
AND BROWN FAMILIES AND THEIR
KIDS.
I HEARD THEIR PAIN, CONFUSION,
AND ANGER, I’VE LEARNED FROM
THEM AND I’VE GROWN FROM THAT.
>> Tucker: THINK ABOUT WHAT
YOU JUST SAW.
IT’S NOT THE NORMAL PANDERING.
MIKE BLOOMBERG BELIEVES
PASSIONATELY IN GUN CONTROL,
IT’S A SIGNATURE ISSUE.
STOP AND FRISK MAY HAVE BEEN THE
MOST EFFECTIVE GUN-CONTROL
POLICY EVER ADMINISTERED
ANYWHERE.
IT TOOK THOUSANDS OF ILLEGAL
FIREARMS OFF THE STREETS OF
NEW YORK.
NEW YORK DEMOCRATIC VOTERS
DECIDED THEY DON’T LIKE IT, THEY
DON’T LIKE STOP AND FRISK IT
WITHOUT PAUSING, BLOOMBERG
GRAVELS AND THE TAXES ON LEGACY.
WHY DID HE DO THAT?
BECAUSE HE DOESN’T CARE.
HE WILL DO WHATEVER IT TAKES.
THEY SAY POLITICIANS ARE
ETHICALLY FLEXIBLE AND, OF
COURSE, THEY ARE PURE THIS IS
DIFFERENT TO READ SOMETHING
OMINOUS ABOUT IT.
BLOOMBERG CAN CHANGE HIS CORE
BELIEFS BECAUSE HE DOESN’T THINK
HIS BELIEFS ARE RELEVANT TO THE
OUTCOME OF THIS RACE.
ONLY HIS WEALTH MATTERS.
THE HORRIFYING FACT IS HE MAY BE
RIGHT.
HOW WEALTHY IS MICHAEL
BLOOMBERG?
THE RICHNESS OF THE RUSSIAN
OLIGARCHS, LADLED MICKELSON, IS
WORTH ABOUT $24 BILLION.
MICHAEL BLOOMBERG COULD
LITERALLY GIVE AWAY TWICE
AMOUNT, OR SPEND IT ON A
PRESIDENTIAL RACE AND COULD
STILL BE FIVE TIMES AS RICH AS
DONALD TRUMP’S.
IT’S STILL HARD TO IMAGINE HOW
MUCH MONEY THAT IS.
BLOOMBERG CAN SEIZE POWER.
A RULING CLASS WHICH WORSHIPS
MONEY ABOVE ALL SEES NOTHING
WRONG WITH IT, THEY ARE EQUAL TO
EAGER TO HELP BLOOMBERG WITH IT.
THEY ARE LIBERTARIAN ON ECONOMIC
MATTERS, SOMETHING THAT SHARED
WITH ONLY A TINY FRACTION OF THE
POPULATION.
NO NORMAL PERSON THINGS THE
WIDENING WEALTH GAP IS A GOOD
THING.
IT’S OBVIOUSLY MAKING AMERICA
UNSTABLE.
BUT MIKE BLOOMBERG HAS BEEN ONE
OF ITS CHIEF BENEFICIARIES.
HE WILL DEFEND THE CURRENT
SYSTEM ABOVE ALL ELSE.
THERE IS A REASON HE IS A
FAVORITE OF FINANCE MOGULS AND
TECH COMMISSARS.
AGAIN, THIS IS A TOTAL DEPARTURE
FROM ANYTHING WE HAVE SEEN
BEFORE IN THE HISTORY OF THIS
COUNTRY.
SAY WHAT YOU WILL ABOUT
DONALD TRUMP, BUT IN 2016 HE RAN
FOR 2016 ON IDEAS THAT LARGE
NUMBERS OF VOTERS ACTUALLY LIKED
WHETHER OR NOT THEY LIKED HIM.
SECURE THE BORDER AND
COUNTERPRODUCTIVE WARS FIGHT THE
FASCISM OF POLITICAL
CORRECTNESS.
IN SELLING THOSE IDEAS, HE SPENT
ABOUT HALF OF WHAT
HILLARY CLINTON’S BAD.
BUT BLOOMBERG CANNOT BE BOTHERED
WITH SELLING IDEAS OR HAVING A
PLATFORM.
DOESN’T CARE WHAT THE
THIS IS THE NIGHTMARE SCENARIO
THAT CAMPAIGN FINANCE REFORM
ACTIVISTS TO TELL US ABOUT.
THEY WERE RIGHT ABOUT ONE THING.
OUR SYSTEM HAS BEEN VULNERABLE
TO PEOPLE LIKE MICHAEL BLOOMBERG
FOR A LONG TIME.
HE’S THE FIRST ONE IS ACTUALLY
TRY TO DO IT.
YOU SHOULD BE ALARMED BY HIS
CAMPAIGN FOR PRESIDENT.
DEMOCRACY DOESN’T BREAK WHEN
VOTERS CHOOSE UNWISELY.
THEY SOMETIMES DO.